now after we showed you last night how
Biden and his team's answers on this
2024 whether he's going to run or not
have been evolving through the year
we have a new entry tonight to bring you
democrat Senator Chris [ __ ] says it's
going to be a while before we get a
definitive answer he said President
Biden has always been someone who talked
about the need for a transition to a new
generation of leaders the question is
just when and it's not clear to me that
he's made up his mind about when that
should happen joining me now is our
reflector Fox News contributor and
former White House Press Secretary Ari
Coons is saying that Joe Biden may wait
until the middle of next year
to decide yeah your thoughts yeah listen
as a republican I would want nothing
more than for Joe Biden to declare for
re-election and run because I would like
to run against guy who's gonna be 82
years old on Election Day or right after
election day in the year 2024. but the
fact of the matter is Laura and I
predicted this last May Joe Biden is not
going to run for reelection and
Christopher [ __ ] Senator Coombs who was
Biden's former Chief of Staff is giving
an early indication of that the Democrat
Party is not especially after they're
going to lose the house may lose the
Senate they're not going to want a
candidate who is about to turn 80 an
unpopular president presiding over a bad
economy to be their leader in the future
Democrats are just not going to want
Biden to step up and run again
now someone who's hinted Ari um that
he'll run if Biden won't is Gavin Newsom
because he did such a bang-up job in
California he's already hitting the
campaign trail with a stop at the
Clinton Global initiative we have to pay
homage there and he bragged about what
he did to California's energy industry
wow
we are as committed and more resolved
than we've ever been
to accelerate this transition and with
all due respect to those conservative
Governors out there Greg Abbott
and others they're as dumb as they want
to be and they're just doubling down on
stupid and we will not follow their path
we're going in a completely different
direction
well Ari who's economic growth
who's that economic growth eclipses
California's
Florida's Texas's because they stayed
open during the pandemic and refused to
give in to the fear mongers
and when it comes to people going in a
different direction Governor Newsom
should be talking about his own
constituents since they're leaving in
California the state is actually
shrinking in population for the first
time in decades look if when Joe Biden
doesn't run Laura we're going to have
some 20 to 30 Democrat candidates run
it's going to be Mayhem and it's a
productive Mayhem I'm a big believer in
primaries is the right way to sort out
the future for either party but it's
going to be Mayhem on the Democrat side
if you remember in 2020 you had two
nights of debates for the Democrats they
had the big kid debate and the little
kid debate and that's going to happen
again that's how many Democrats are
going to throw their hat in the ring but
the Democrats need a generational change
and most Democrats know it and admit it
when you look at the age of Senator
Chuck Schumer and Nancy Pelosi Joe Biden
it's a it's a team led by 80 year olds
and up and no the American people the
Democratic party we're a country that
wants renewal we want Fresh Starts we
want new people Joe Biden can say to the
American people he did his job he
defeated Donald Trump that's what he'll
retire when and remember
but it's time for somebody new on the
Democratic side and that's the message
that Democrats are going to be saying
Republicans want him to run
all right Ari great to see you tonight
as always hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else